if you want to become a billionaire the
most probable way to get there is
starting a company over the years there
have been a couple of billionaires who
are able to make their wealth through
diligent investing making movies and
even writing books but despite the
specific avenue nearly all billionaires
can attribute their wealth to some sort
of individual venture whether that be
starting a hedge fund or pursuing
directing there are however a small
group of individuals who were able to
hit the elusive 10 figure mark working
as employees their entire lives
the first person to achieve this
remarkable feat was a cuban refugee
named roberto goyzuetta
so here's how a cuban refugee became the
world's first nine-to-five billionaire
roberto goizuetta was born on november
18th 1931 in havana cuba
when roberto was a kid the family was
actually quite well off his father was
an architect and owned a successful
construction hardware business
meanwhile his mother was the heir to a
large sugar plantation roberto actually
grew up in a mansion that his
grandfather built so life was pretty
good he attended local private schools
in havana during his early days before
attending a preparatory school called
cheshire academy in new haven
connecticut roberto would end up doing
well enough in school to get accepted
into yale university where he majored in
chemical engineering roberto graduated
from yale in 1953 and right after
graduation roberto would marry olga
castellero and move back to havana
after graduation his father really
wanted roberto to work in the family
business but roberto had other plans
roberto wanted to make a name for
himself instead of following in his
father's footsteps so he looked around
the newspaper when he found an
advertisement from an unidentified
company that was looking for a bilingual
chemical engineer
the company turned out to be coca-cola
and roberto would get the job however
his father only let roberto take the job
if he agreed to work at the family
company every saturday roberto agreed to
his father's condition and took the job
on july 4th 1954 the job wasn't
particularly glamorous but it did pay
500 per month which is the same as about
5 000 today
apparently his friends thought that he
was crazy for taking a job at coca-cola
instead of working for his father's
company but soon enough this would turn
out to be the right decision over the
next five years roberto quickly worked
up the corporate ladder becoming the
chief technical director for all five of
coca-cola's bottling plants in cuba
at this point it seemed like nothing
could go wrong
roberto had a solid career going and
even if he lost his job he had a great
family to back him up but this is when
cuba would experience an unprecedented
turn of events
in january of 1959 communist leader
fidel castro led a rebellion against the
cuban government and he would
successfully overthrow the government
just a month later
fidel castro instantly named himself the
premier of the country and made it clear
that he was going to take over all
private businesses roberto quickly sent
his children to stay with relatives in
the us
but roberto and his parents would try to
stick it out in cuba for as long as
possible
eventually in august of 1960 the family
decided that it was time to get out and
they would use a family vacation to
miami as an excuse to flee the country
when they reached miami the family had
successfully escaped communism but they
had lost everything in the process
the family was staying at a small motel
room and they only had 40 dollars and
100 shares of coca-cola left to make
things worse just two months later the
new cuban government would seize all of
coca-cola's assets in cuba as well as
the family's assets
so there was officially no going back
the only silver lining of the situation
was that coca-cola didn't lay off or
fire roberto but given that coca-cola
had lost all of their assets in cuba
roberto had to start again from the
bottom
in 1961 coca-cola moved roberto to the
bahamas where he worked as a chemist
given roberto's previous experience
though it didn't take too long for him
to work up the corporate ladder once
again
by 1963 roberto was promoted to staff
assistant to the senior vice president
for latin america and in 1964 roberta
was transferred to coke's headquarters
in atlanta georgia just two years after
that roberto was promoted to vice
president of technical research and
development which made him the youngest
person in history to reach that position
but this was just the beginning while
roberto was working as a vice president
the former chairman of coca-cola robert
woodruff would become quite impressed
with roberta's performance woodruff was
77 years old at the time and he had just
retired from coca-cola a few years ago
but he still played a crucial role
within the company soon enough woodruff
and roberto would become friends and
often ate lunch together it's thought
that woodruff considered roberto to be
his disciple several years later in 1974
roberta was promoted to senior vice
president of the technical division and
just one year after that he was promoted
to executive vice president of the
technical division roberto served as one
of coca-cola's executive vice presidents
till 1979 when the president of
coca-cola j lucien smith resigned this
allowed roberto to move up to being a
vice chairman of the company at the time
coca-cola had six vice chairman and
these guys were considered to be the
next in line for becoming chairman and
ceo
however within a year the system would
be changed four of the vice chairmen
would become executive vice presidents
and roberto would take on three roles
which were director president and chief
operating officer
as ceo roberto eliminated natural sugar
from coca-cola sodas instead he opted
for high-fructose corn syrup which was
40 cheaper this clever business decision
further impressed woodruff and just a
year later in 1981 when paul austin the
former ceo retired roberto would be
named the new ceo and chairman of
coca-cola with a strong recommendation
from woodruff and this is when roberto
would really prove his ability
you see coca-cola was doing just fine in
terms of revenue and profits but a storm
was brewing in the background coca-cola
sales had flatline for quite some time
and this wasn't because coca-cola had
reached market saturation the soft drink
market was still growing and the reason
coca-cola didn't see any growth was
because pepsi was eating it all up
thanks to the marketing genius of john
scully coca-cola was still outselling
pepsi at soda fountains but pepsi had
actually overtaken coca-cola within the
food store market since 1979 and they
were quickly building up market share so
roberto arranged an executive meeting
where he explained his plan for the
1980s the key point he hammered with
this meeting was the need for
reinvestment in his mind the idea was
simple borrow money at low interest
rates invested in high returning assets
and then pocket the difference but this
was a completely foreign idea to
coca-cola coca-cola had never borrowed
money in their entire history and this
made many executives skeptical about
roberto's plan they all knew that
coca-cola needed major change to win
back market share from pepsi though so
they went along with it roberto's first
major decision was the introduction of
new drinks the first of which being diet
coke in 1982 diet coke was a massive
success and roberta would follow this up
with cherry coke in 1985 which also
became a major moneymaker for coca-cola
roberto wasn't free of mistakes though
in 1985 roberto also oversaw the release
of new coke which changed the formula of
classic coke though coca-cola had
gathered a significant amount of
objective data that people like the
taste of new coke better than the
original coke the market didn't actually
respond that well
there was something about the nostalgia
and familiarity of original coke that
even coca-cola themselves couldn't beat
roberto did not make a fuss over this
weird reaction though he quickly
listened to the market and brought back
the original coke formula within just 79
days
aside from experimenting with new drinks
roberto completely overhauled
coca-cola's marketing effort
until then coca-cola was extremely
passive with their marketing roberto
changed this by introducing slogans like
coca-cit you can't beat the feeling and
always coca-cola this aggressive style
carried into the company's expansion
efforts as well
for instance after the berlin wall fell
in 1989 roberto instantly expanded the
company into eastern europe despite the
terrible economic condition of the area
while this was a questionable move at
the time coke overtook pepsi as the
preferred soft drink in europe just 3
years later
this aggressive marketing made coca-cola
one of the most recognized brands in the
world it's estimated that 94 of the
entire world's population recognizes
coke's red and white logo
roberto also spent a lot of money on
vertical integration throughout the
1980s roberto invested into a variety of
different bottling companies which
allowed coca-cola to significantly
reduce their operating costs and
increase their profits for a bit of time
roberto also experimented with
investments outside of the beverage
industry for example in 1992 coca-cola
bought columbia pictures for 692 million
dollars at first the investment actually
performed poorly but after the release
of ghostbusters columbia pictures
exploded and roberto was able to sell
the company in 1989 for a 1.5 billion
profit despite the success though
roberto decided that it was best to
focus on just one industry roberto
strongly believed that the sole purpose
of every company was to maximize
shareholder returns and as long as a
later accomplished this good things
would follow
in his opinion the most effective way to
accomplish this was being focused and
being aggressive and that's exactly what
he did
unfortunately though roberta's career
would abruptly come to an end during his
peak roberto had been a lifelong
cigarette smoker and in september of
1997 he would be diagnosed with lung
cancer he would die just one month later
on october 19 1997 at age 65. despite
roberto's untimely death he had already
done wonders for coca-cola by 1996
coca-cola was outselling pepsi
internationally by a ratio of three to
one and as you would guess profits and
stock price had gone to the moon
when roberto took over coca-cola in 1981
the company was worth a solid 2.8
billion dollars but shortly after his
death coca-cola was worth 184 billion
dollars that's equivalent to a 64x
return within just 17 years to put that
into perspective coca-cola's talk has
only grown 31 percent since roberto's
death no wonder warren buffett made so
much off of coca-cola this phenomenal
performance has made roberto goyswetta
one of the most respected and highly
regarded ceos of all time
and many of his business philosophies
are taught in the most prestigious
business schools around the world today
considering all of this i don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that roberto
was worth 1.3 billion at the time of his
death making him the world's first
employee billionaire
what do you guys think about roberta's
insane rise to the top comment that down
below
also drop a like if you love coke and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm ari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]